I think overall the world is struggling
with creating jobs and countries like
India for example are putting in 1
million people every month month after
month into the job market and it's hard
for even India to you know find jobs for
everyone globally technology slower
economies are all creating pressure on
jobs and when jobs are at a stay are at
stake is the emotions that they call and
I think job for us here at ICC is to
fight emotions with facts the u.s. under
Obama administration put out a heavy
duty on import of tires automobile tires
they save 12-hundred jobs and that's a
fact but every job costed them nine
hundred thousand dollars to save so it's
not a good trade we must be open we
cannot repeat the mistakes of 1930s when
the world went inwards and the whole
global economy collapsed we need to look
forward how concerned are you about
brexit and the potential disruption
that's going to cause for trade
particularly in Europe I think this is
part of the discourse when you talk
about new administration in the u.s. you
talk about brexit and these are the new
areas of discussions around these
emotive subjects of anti-immigration
stopping the movement of people securing
local jobs so brexit is an outcome of
that vote when it came out I was in
Scotland on that day and I saw
Sutherland in the night going the other
way
and I was quite shocked and I didn't
expect this outcome but I'm hopeful that
the United Kingdom will come out of this
fairly strongly because in the end this
is an important nation to the world the
current budget spoke about certain
concessions to the businesses so I think
you can find his own momentum but I
would really want it to see being part
of the common market
they must negotiate a good deal they
cannot isolate themselves they need to
be part of the world global trading
system but you think brexit potentially
gives the UK the opportunity to forge
stronger trade ties with countries like
India that it does because India has
been locked down with lot of EU issues
and some of the trade issues that we
wanted to resolve in the UK we couldn't
in the past and we had Prime Minister
main India two months back
and I think there was a momentum towards
that given that it'll be an independent
country outside now the control of EU
India should benefit what we have you
here you run India's biggest mobile
phone operator Bharti Airtel you're
currently number one Vodafone and Idea
Cellular the two and three players are
getting together leapfrogging you do you
welcome this deal I welcome it in fact I
had welcomed it even before it was
announced because it makes a million
sense to consolidate the market I'm also
the chairman of GSM a as a global
telecom body and last month in Barcelona
I made an appeal to the regulators
around the globe allow and encourage
consolidation you can't have twelve
players in a market and then be viable
with this merger I think we'll be down
to four operators in India and that will
be right level of competition right for
the customers but equally right for the
balance sheets of these companies would
I an idea coming together
forms a strong formidable balance sheet
a good strong player but my own view is
this is also in some sense water phones
saying goodbye to India really you think
ultimately this is first step on them
quitting mean you're all together I
would say so what often is not used to
just being an investor in a minority
share holding but if they have to
orderly come out of the Indian market
this is the best way to do it core some
would say that ultimately they could go
the other one take full control of this
joint venture unlikely